tonight on channel 8 cbs will celebrate
america's love of animals anchored by
jane pauley the pet project looks at all
aspects of our passion for pets
our newsroom pet guru denise valdez
brings us a story
of a local artist who met her calling
and changed her career after adopting a
dog
graphic designer jennifer hart changed
course
to illustrator and author because of
this guy
i think just dogs in general are just
super kind and
curious that curious nature inspired
hart to write and draw a story with
baxter as the central character
he's really kind of embodied what i've
been trying to
bring in these teaching moments in the
books baxter goes to
imagination land is a whimsical story of
fantasy and fun
encouraging creativity kindness
acceptance
and adventure one of the things i love
about picture books is you have these
really
big concepts that you can kind of bring
into these smaller worlds i think
humor is a great way to you know help
kids understand a big idea
the pair visit schools sharing his voice
both on the page and in real life it's
been really fun to do it with him you
know because i get to bring him to
events sometimes and the kids always
react really
sweetly to him the positive response has
led to a collection of
short stories and more books and the
baxter meets his
his monster yeah what was the message
for kids in this one
through this story he learns to not
judge this creature by the way that they
look but gets to know them and
understand that
they have a lot in common and that you
know sometimes monsters
really aren't monsters at all they're
just a little misunderstood
more baxter the dog books are in the
works and hart hopes kids can make them
part of their bedtime
reading maybe even snuggling up with
their favorite pet
denise valdez 8 news now